To find her way
back to the gravel beds
where she was born.
This mom to be has an amazing memory,
following sights and smells
logged in her brain
when she first swam out to sea.
Where there's a fork in the river
She knows exactly
which way to turn.
She's on track.
But unfortunately for her,
her spawning grounds lie above a 30 mile
gantlet, fast flowing rapids,
vicious whirlpools and towering
waterfalls.
But she's
no ordinary fish.
She can lead the human equivalent
of a four story building,
but she's got to do it again
and again.
Halfway
there,
she's exhausted.
She's not just fighting
the current.
No longer feeding
many salmon are already wasting away.
Precious energy used up,
morphing their bodies ready to breed.
Some years
90% don't make it to spawn.
Only the toughest moms
to be have enough in the tank
for one final giant hurdle.
She can only jump halfway,
but thrashing her tail, she can power up
the final few feet
and over the lip of the floor.
Just a few more miles to go.